the sense in which ideas in this
oligarchical system which we call you
know democracy tend to Prevail over good
ideas is that the bad ideas are
empowering even if these ideas actually
harm these victims which I would argue
you know they do they feel good and the
society that we're living in you know
that that promotion of bad ideas has
gotten so strong that the bad ideas are
now able to use authoritarian techniques
to repress the good ideas the mechanism
that basically creates that coordination
of ideology is promotion rather than
suppression it's attraction rather than
repulsion what about these unbiased you
know experts but the thing is you give
power to the experts and power corrupts
them and suddenly they become they
develop these conflicts of interest they
become sort of corrupted and basically
when you give power to the market place
of ideas the marketplace of ideas
corrupts itself and you get basically a
world of absolutely terrible ideas
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today has
gone from an anonymous blogger to one of
the intellectual Godfathers of the
so-called new right courtesy oven
welcome to trigonometry thank you so
much and I'm enjoying being here and
being in the UK well it's great to have
you on the show
um we'll get into whether new right is
the right term uh but before we do that
and all the rest of it tell us who are
you how are you where you are what's
been the journey that brings you to be
sitting here well I'm an American and
um and and here I am right and I just
turned 50 years old and it's been a a
rather strange and interesting Journey
um I actually grew up
um as a what we call a Foreign Service
brat so I grew up in the as a child at
the American Foreign Service in case you
don't know the uh the Foreign Service I
believe you have one of of your own we
go around the world and and Rule it
essentially and you know perhaps one of
my we used to do that here yeah well you
know you still help us well you know for
this and that yeah and and you know
perhaps my in terms of formative you
know intellectual experiences perhaps my
most formative moment was when I was 15
years old and my father was Consul in a
Porto they have very very fine wine
there and uh and I was reading his his
for his unclassified cables back to
America and he used to have me proofread
them and I'm reading these cables and it
suddenly struck me that the relationship
between the US and Portugal although on
paper it's a symmetric relationship
there's something asymmetric there and
and I sort of realized that actually the
purpose of the U.S diplomatic mission in
Portugal is not to relate between equals
you know we have this treaty that says
if Portugal is attacked perhaps by
Morocco or Spain or even the Soviets
America will come to its defense but
also if America is attacked by Canada or
Mexico for example
um Portugal will help defend us and I'm
like you know actually why are there 50
Americans
um some of the best Americans in the
world
um in Portugal I mean wonderful people
in the Foreign Service I've only praised
for them but uh their goal is their
mission is clearly to in fact supervise
the government of Portugal and uh and
and so to basically sort of go from this
world view of kind of you know this
world view of the Cold War liberal that
I grew up in reading the international
Herald Tribune The Economist and like
suddenly I'm like this is this is an
Empire and and you know thucydides would
have recognized it as just as unequal as
the Delian League and and that sort of
sparked I mean you know I stirred that
away
um you know for a number of years
um I'm actually retired computer
programmer computer scientist some
people might even say although and and
after
um
2000 um I started working on a computer
science research project and you know
research is hard you read a lot of books
and uh you know to pass the time when
your brain isn't isn't on the computer
science and I started to sort of um
really through the the reading of
Libertarians such as mises and rothbard
and rothbart student uh Hunter I don't
know if you know the name
um he wrote this book democracy The God
That Failed and you know he was he was a
Libertarian but he's sort of bringing me
you know bringing in this world view
from kind of before the Democratic
Revolution and really opening you to the
very difficult question of how our
ancestors would see us you know we have
this picture of our ancestors but we've
seldom reverse the question you know we
know what we think of Elizabeth the
first well would Elizabeth the first
think of us you know we're sitting here
right next to Westminster Abbey uh you
know what would she think what would she
say if she can see Britain today and our
attitude toward the past you know as I
started to read the writers of the past
I got into him like huge admirer of
Thomas Carlisle who's now you know very
unknown and very misunderstood and as I
started to sort of read the past I
started to get a sense of kind of
stepping outside you know whether it's
the Overton window or Plato's Cave or
um whatever I started to get get a sense
of how the past would see the present
you know we live in a time that
considers itself very very Superior to
all of human history in a number of
respects and you know when you look at
our cell phones our computers you know
these things are sort of clearly
superior but are we as Superior as human
beings our values and perspectives
Superior
um this seems to me to be a subject well
worthy of debate and especially what
started to concern me is that there's a
sort of almost a sort of provincialism
to the present because when you're in a
very provincial Society uh you tend to
be very centered on where you are and
you dismiss sort of the rest of the
world is heathens barbarians you know
and you know you sell them in this sort
of provincial context you basically
seldom sort of flip the script and say
what would they think of us and to be
sort of Cosmopolitan in the present is
to be able to flip that script and think
this is how we see the Mongolians but
this is also how the Mongolians see us
and so you know to answer the question
of how the elizabethans would see us of
how Shakespeare would see the present
you know sort of opened up this kind of
vast unopened field of of thought and I
felt that you know and in a way you know
by starting to think this way I felt
myself you know sort of as one might say
exiting the Matrix and you know the
thing that I'm kind of most notorious
for
in some ways is back in 2007 I was
sitting in a cafe in the hate Ashbury
District of San Francisco
um it's called The People's cafe coffee
the people it was covered with 60s you
know propaganda from the from that time
and I was thinking about you know this
great movie The Matrix and it was like
and of course when we think about kind
of um
breaking our frames as I was taught to
think of course you grow up in the 20th
century I mean very much I'm very much a
child of the 20th century you grew up
thinking of your you know breaking your
frames as sort of a revolt against
traditionalism and and to sort of take
that and flip it around and turn it into
a revolt against the present
uh it seemed like a very subversive act
and so I started to use this metaphor
from The Matrix of the red pill and now
everyone you know has this this metaphor
of being red pilled or pilled or
whatever which uh you know actually this
metaphor was far too powerful for me it
was rested for me immediately in two
directions at the same time in my very
abstruse content they broke open the
pill they dumped out my in a very
abstract you know criticisms of of
Carlisle and whatever and uh it was
replaced um the one by the pickup artist
Community who started to talk about
being red pilled in terms of seeing the
uh you know the truth about women or
whatever and then of course uh by uh you
know full on Nazis are rather neo-nazis
and or post-nazis or you know the party
office is no longer issuing membership
cards but uh you know the term is still
used and so it's sort of you know I I
obviously I'm not going to take credit
for everything that's described as as
red pilled you became more mainstream
than either of those two eventually yes
yes eventually eventually it became sort
of more generalized and mainstreamed and
now it's lovely because it means almost
nothing but um you know to you know and
and at the same time and this would have
definitely happened without Lee a lot of
people as sort of the ideas of the 1960s
kind of hardened you know out of their
kind of original freshness because these
ideas felt very fresh you know 15 60
years ago kind of hardened into a kind
of Orthodoxy and so people were looking
for ways to controvert that Orthodoxy to
deny it to sort of push back against it
especially in sort of anonymous places
on the internet and so you've got this
sort of world of like 4chan you're
familiar with 4chan it was never a 4chan
person but you know a lot there was a
lot of sort of seething ferment of you
know how
strongly people in that could basically
spit in the face of the powers that be
and and the people you know who
the people in that world uh you know
which is a world I sort of you know
um
I kind of I I respect people in a lot of
ways who are sort of performative
dissidents who have this kind of purely
negative nihilistic Vision but there
actually I think has to be something
more than than pure nihilism you know
when you're in an Orthodoxy nihilism is
sort of very attractive and um I think
that that one of the things that happens
you know all around the world is people
kids go to these schools and you know
they sort of receive this content which
strikes them as is very wrong and very
disturbing at a certain point they go to
their teacher
and they say
um you know maybe in deep confidence uh
you know I don't believe in any of this
stuff it seems wrong it seems very
strange this obsession with the race
seems very odd and very unpleasant and
we're taught you know at the same time
in the US to believe we have these two
concepts of equal protection of the law
and protected classes how did these
things you know interact you know it's
very orwellian
um but you know if I don't believe in
this
what do I believe in and the teacher
says to them well it's very simple the
opposite of this is being a Nazi and at
this point your 15 year old says well
done I'm a Nazi and I'm using the
British pronunciation uh you know just
because I'm here in the UK and and
that's the sort of like that
antagonism where basically you're part
of the kind of stereotyped you're sort
of when you do that and you know I like
to warn people against that choice
because it's not that to be a Nazi is to
be too radical actually I think you must
be much more radical than that but it's
like the sort of you know you're you're
inhabiting this caricatured opposition
to the frame whereas actually to be
outside the frame is much bigger and
much more interesting and that's much
more enormous let's talk about that so
you I I want to give you an opportunity
to also clarify what you said being more
radical than a naughty what are you
talking about so uh you know I would say
for example that um you know to take
Shakespeare seriously is much more
radical than being Nazi and so you know
when you look at the world of Elizabeth
the first
um it's a world that when we when we
take it seriously we can almost we can
barely understand so for example I you
know it's a digression but I happen to
be like like many very intellectual
people that happen to be a nuts 40 and I
believe that uh Shakespeare was the role
of Oxford and so for example to take the
world of Elizabethan Court poetry
seriously and to take there's a
wonderful speech in troyless and
Cressida where Ulysses sort of has this
kind of Defense of inequality in his
defense of rank and his defense of like
nobility you'll not find an ounce of
democratic sentiment in Shakespeare you
know whereas for example Hitler is a
demagogue you know he's a very and and
if you look at for example the
relationship between
Hitler and and the kind of the German
nationalists right great rental writers
like Ernst Junior
um who you know there's recently I don't
you know younger there's recently been a
younger Revival amazing amazing writer
and these people look down upon Hitler
as a sort of peasant you know and and
anti-Semitism you know in German Society
in 1900 you know was a sort of peasant
belief you know the idea that it can
become a serious thing that would result
in serious consequences for people was
Unthinkable to these German Aristocrats
and so for example if I you know place
myself in that in that time I'm sort of
with
um much more with the kind of
steffenberg kind of the old German
aristocratic right who tried to
eventually tried to blow up Hitler with
a bomb and and failed and Junior himself
is almost caught up in these purges and
and killed but Aaron stewner Solomon
um Friedrich wreck uh some people you
probably haven't heard of you know those
for me are the writers to read from the
time and so to say for example that
you're an anti-nazi you know you could
basically say okay if you're an
anti-nazi you could be a stalinist my
own grandparents in America were
stalinists they were they were you know
Jewish kindness of of Russian origin I
think like some of your ancestors in
fact I believe our names end with the
same last two letters
um and and and so to say that you're not
a Nazi it's like you know one of my
favorite things to explain is the word
Gentile because when we use the word
Gentile it's a negative set it means
that you're not a Jew or in Utah it
means that you're not a Mormon actually
you and I could go I was just in Utah
but they didn't tell me that you were
you were a gentile in Utah
um and and you know regardless of your
ethnic origin you're a gentile because
it means you're not a Mormon so you're
not a Mormon you could be a Hindu you
could be a zoroastrian and so you know
to say what do Gentiles think
what is Gentile thinking is you know
fundamentally a parochial and false
categorization so to say what to
anti-nazis think you could be a
stalinist you could be an American
liberal your could be Ernst junior or
Julius evilla
and so so to sort of expand basically
once you say going back to my example of
the 15 year old kid to say okay I'm not
woke I'm post-woke whatever you know
what does that mean you know this word
woke dates to 2012 is as though we
invented these ideas in 2012 which is
absolute nonsense they were being taught
on American universities in the 70s they
were actually you know go back solidly
to the 30s and you know so to say that
I'm not this it you know once you say
that not this means that you're sort of
making the mistake of saying Gentiles
believe this right and and to to escape
from that pattern and say no actually
you know to say I don't believe for
example you know to say you know the
meaning of I don't believe in democracy
you know that can be have a huge number
of meanings but to group for example um
Hitler and Elizabeth the first
either of whom believed in democracy I
mean I can't imagine that um you know
Queen Elizabeth would have let that
little man in in her presence for more
than a few minutes uh and you know and
and so sort of it's so crucial to
basically say okay I'm escaping from
this you know dichotomy and even to sort
of view this dichotomy as kind of a
single line and say okay well I don't
believe in woke so but I'm not Hitler
but let's go you know ten percent Port
Hitler I'm a moderate I'm a moderate you
know uh you know as they say the best
way to fight in a radical racist
terrorism is to support moderate racists
and oh no wait they don't say that and
and so there are all these other
different fascinating amazing directions
to go to when you kind of let yourself
out of the very narrow prison of the
present and kind of into the past and so
you know when I speak I of course like
to you know kind of red pill people are
kind of living within this very
constrained intellectual universe and
say you can get outside this but you
know I also like to speak to the Nazis
and you know I want to say actually
you know there's a sort of paucity of
imagination and there's a sort of when
you do that you're kind of remaining
within the frame and it's very important
to sort of leave that frame and so like
my example of the um you know the 15
year old the brilliant 15 year old kid
who becomes a Nazi which I've seen
millions and millions of cases of okay
not Millions but very many and it's sort
of very sad because you get sort of
Trapped in that space and especially
you're sort of looking for what is the
most taboo belief in the modern world
you end up in anti-Semitism and
Holocaust denial well um you know the
Holocaust is one of the best attested
facts uh you know in history but uh if
you're looking for the truths about
World War II actually almost every other
World War II conspiracy theory is true
except Holocaust denial and so President
Roosevelt had prior knowledge of Pearl
Harbor totally believe this for example
like you know I don't want to go into
the details on this but you know and and
so when we understand this sort of enemy
like if you look at kind of Pop history
professional history kind of studies of
the Third Reich you know we understand
it clearly is glass we see Hitler almost
perfectly understanding Stalin
oh you know have you read there's a
reasonable book Stalin's were by Sean
mcmeeken they came out a lovely history
you know kind of a revisionist history
or someone but impeccably academic of
you know sort of Stalin's perspective in
the war
um kind of recapitulates the Icebreaker
hypothesis yeah you know that you know
why it's funny because that is I'm not I
there's most conspiracy theories I think
are complete nonsense but there's a few
Russian writers and the one you're
talking about is actually been vetted
yeah he's been bettered by other people
including salonian who I mean that's a
legit thing that Stalin wanted to stamp
Hitler in the back that's why they
signed in on aggression yes yes yes and
I happen to also believe that FDR had
prior knowledge of that and I there's no
way to prove it can't be proved
um you know only circumstantial evidence
and so the thing is when you sort of go
back and kind of look at that period you
know again you know when you're just
like okay something smells funny I'm a
Nazi you know you're just missing all of
this subtlety and all of this you know
actually this amazing history you know
you can be Charles beard President
Roosevelt in the coming of the war
Charles Callan tansel was the leading
American diplomatic historian of the
time he was granted unfettered access to
State Department papers uh he wrote
backdoor to war which is basically like
you know FDR organized this war which
killed I mean and well I mean was it
good for the Jews you know as one says
right and so you know this is sort of
tremendous catastrophe actually you know
the book that I recommend you know the
writer Nicholson Baker no amazing
American writer novelist he's written
fiction non-fiction really one of
America's great writers and you wrote
this book about 15 years ago called
human smoke and human smoke is a history
of World War II told in chronological
tweet length excerpts from primary
sources it's amazing and you know you
come away from this and there's just one
thing that I kind of want people to
believe about World War II is that it
was not a Marvel movie
it was not in any sense a Marvel movie
there's no there's no Marvel movies
history World War One my gosh you know
uh certainly not a Marvel movie and and
so you know when you step outside of
this material you really really really
need to step outside of this sort of you
know linear you know you know here I'm
I'm a progressive here I'm a Nazi and
you know by the way when we use the word
Progressive
um
my grandparents actually were American
Communists they were stalinists uh to be
exact and they met at a Communist Party
meeting I believe in the late 20s or
early 30s and they were stalinous all
the way through the 70s which took a lot
of a lot of you know persistence
to apologize yeah
for for you're not responsible for the
sins of your ancestors keep trying to
make the point there there you go I
don't believe I'm responsible but you
know it provides a certain I'll take the
reparation it provides a certain
accountability for sort of understanding
what went on
um and I only learned that my you know
they were so secretive it was such a
secret of time I only learned that my
grandparents were Communists from my
parents my grandparents themselves would
never talk about it the word they used
instead was Progressive
they only said Progressive and if you go
back and there's a wonderful resource
called marxist.org
um it's about this fella Carl Karl Marx
But it includes a lot of sort of leftist
you know archival material from the past
and you can go and read the pages of the
Communist which was the official Journal
of the cpusa and you can look at the way
they use the word Progressive and they
used it in exactly the same way to
describe the same set of people it is
always a positive word it always means
our friends and so in a way when you use
the word Progressive you know without
realizing it today you know the old left
becomes the new left so the old left in
America is the kind of party left it's
it's centralized and the new left which
consists largely of if you know the term
red diaper baby not that we use in the
US red diaper baby means sort of a child
of the Party World and so like my father
for example is a red diaper baby and
um yeah in the new Left basically kind
of takes kind of the value system of
1930s communism and it becomes a
decentralized thing there's no longer a
party you know it's now this sort of
movement that that sweeps through
Society but if you look at the
connections between what people who were
Communists in the 1930s and everyone
cool in the 1930s was Communist almost
exclusively
um and and it was it was just an amazing
group of people I mean they were
brilliant they were like you know when I
try to explain 30s communism to people
today I'm like you know okay maybe you
went to gifted school maybe we're a
little smart you're watching you know a
very intellectual podcast probably you
know you've got a little bit up top
um imagine all the gifted kids in the
world decided to form a party to take
over the world
that was American communism an amazing
amazing experience and what this
experience sort of you know devolves
into is you know
first of all it becomes like
progressivism and people sort of forget
where progressivism comes from there's a
sort of history of American
anti-communism which sort of takes on
these kind of nationalist overtones and
thinks of it as like this you know sort
of infection stemming from Moscow I'm
like how to get to Moscow
um how to get to Moscow you know you
know in in of course because of course
in Russian intellectual history you have
the spectrum of easternizers versus
westernizers so you on the one hand you
have Lenin nachev you know krupatkin
people like that and on the other hand
you have dostogeevsky povanosov do you
know Pocono you do I I know that that
got to me that you're talking about yes
I'm just aware that Francis hasn't asked
a question
no I'm really into well I'm really first
of all it's because I'm really enjoying
you talk about it and I'm really
enjoying the way that you analyze
what has happened and it's a very
different lens I guess my question to
you Curtis is you've identified
the problems yes so what is your vision
uh what doesn't like Vision
um
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russia men who clean up executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
so my vision is essentially to see
either present as sort of continuous
with the past and my vision is to kind
of in a way
break out of kind of
not even you know is a progressive the
20th century Revolution but um really to
ask questions about the 19th century
revolution in the 18th century
Revolution and so you know for example
one of my favorite writers is you know
the name Joseph de Maestra so de Maestra
is uh he was trained as an Enlightenment
man he was trained basically in school
of Voltaire and he basically sort of you
know criticizes the French Revolution
from his somewhat safe position as a
minister in in Savoy and you know to
sort of find the French Revolution
discussed in a book you know published
in 1797 that could as well apply to the
Russian Revolution to sort of you know
even although so much of the 20th
century bloodthirstiness has vanished
which is I think absolutely wonderful
we're very we're very peaceful people
and you know this is one of the reasons
why I can imagine kind of very great
political change happening in a peaceful
way whereas most people see it as sort
of violent you know imagine sort of you
know the fall of the Soviet Union from
the perspective of a 1920s Bolshevik of
like the era of like War communism they
could have never imagined that this
enormous thing would disappear without a
fight or that you would see sort of the
Velvet Revolution Insurance because they
would have been the ones that physically
suppressed it with correct yeah yeah
that's right that's right that's right
and and if you'd ask basically you know
and this is why I'm sort of you know in
a way of leading up to you know this
answer is that most people imagine a
kind of political change like this only
coming you know at the expense of great
violence and if you'd asked uh and and I
don't believe that's necessary or
desirable even possible and and if you'd
asked basically
the Bolshevik of the 1920s to look at
the events of 1989 to 1991 he would have
been very confused because what he would
have seen is this uh basically the fall
of the Soviet Union was brought about by
um a windbag and a drunk that is
Gorbachev and Yeltsin
um sometimes I could think yakovlev was
was most of the ideas of glasnos and
perestroika came from yakovlev these are
not great individuals he's not violent
individuals there's a crowd of a few
thousand people in front of the Russian
presidential Palace you know Etc et
cetera et cetera and this old Bolshevik
would be like well where's where's the
Soviet youth where's the consumable you
know what is how what is the compsible
do how many people are in the console
mall and you'd be like well there's
about a hundred thousand people in the
constable and where where are they where
why are they not fighting for Soviet
power it's like well they mainly join
the Constable to get jobs
you know and so sort of all of the
energy and power and people who are like
progressives today don't really realize
where this came from and so the the
ability for these kind of you know
intense revolutions to kind of collapse
completely in a way and to sort of lose
their Force you know is fairly
considerable and so you know to answer
your question very directly
um
I'm a monarchist I used to say I was a
royalist to you know distinguish myself
from the people here who believe in in
costumes and and so on you know uh what
we have is this in this country what you
have in this country is this kind of
costume monarchy you know which is
purely symbolic in nature and um you
know one of the questions I ask is very
simply what would Elizabeth the first
have thought of Elizabeth II
and you know and and that's a like once
you you put yourself in that framework
you know the answer is obvious
um you know so when I say I'm a
monarchist I'm I'm a Believer in
essentially absolute though accountable
monarchy which strikes everyone is very
very strange sorry yeah I was gonna say
so let's look at the globe
so who who would be your idea of an
effective absolute monarchy are we
talking about something like Saudi
Arabia are we talking about the U.S
Crown Prince uh you know
um these are very foreign you know one
of the difficulties is that you have to
go to sort of very foreign countries to
look for an equivalent at The Sovereign
level so you know if you're looking at
20th Century political leaders who are
essentially monarchs who I admire
greatly
um leak one you of Singapore who is an
away an Englishman he's a sort of
Englishman
um is because Singapore is the strange
half asian thing
um you know did an amazing job with that
country Deng Xiang ping you know is
arguably the greatest leader of the 20th
century if you look at kind of the
transformation of China under his
leadership he takes this absolute crap
power that's created by Mal who was a
God an absolute nut and then you know
the power of Mao he's an absolute nut
and like Stalin you know the revolution
eats its own he needs to destroy kind of
all the people who brought him to power
so that he can rule alone
and Mao is this you know crazed Chinese
emperor and somehow through the turmoil
of Chinese politics he's replaced by
this intensely practical person doing
Xiaoping who sort of turns this deranged
third world country into you know as I
look around this room
um
think about all the things in this room
that were made in a monarchy
you know those cameras
made in a monarchy can you make that in
Britain no you could you could yeah
it would be a lot worse it would cost a
lot more and this must remind you at a
certain level again over The Late Soviet
Union there's a wonderful uh so do you
know the director Christoph kislowski he
did um the three colors you know Poland
you know communist Poland had this great
film tradition right and Kozlowski was
trained under the you know the Communist
system he later uh you know he he went
to France he's one of the great
directors of our time but he did this
film blind chance
and in blind chance there's a lovely
scene where a Polish communist
bureaucrat has gone to Paris you know
these visits to the West were like
jealously guarded and one of the things
he did when you visited the West Was of
course to shop and he's brought back
from Japan a solar calculator and
there's a scene of these you know you
know it's like the 80s and there's a
scene of these 80s communist
apparatchics just looking at the solar
calculator and thinking we can't do that
and so you know when you look at you
know China for example I'm I'm from
California we're trying to build
High-Speed Rail there you know if you
look at a map of the Chinese you know
subway system the high-speed rail system
it's like a cancer sproutings you know
uh in California they've been trying to
build a high-speed rail line between San
Francisco and Los Angeles but hang on a
second so you're talking about
Innovation here look but what about the
weakest what about the weakest what
about what about the uyghurs um and so
you know when you look at um and and
this is one of the points about 20th
century you know monarchies essentially
is that when you look at 20th Century
monarchies or as we like to say
dictatorships and and you're seeing
essentially you see all of these kind of
atrocities and basically one of the
things that you know the Lord Acton you
know great Englishmen said that absolute
power corrupts absolutely and I used to
believe that I used to be a kind of a
classical liberal even a Libertarian and
um
I started to realize at a certain point
why you know you have you know these
sort of new monarchies these fascisms in
the 20th century Hitler being the worst
probably you know the best of the 20th
century fascist leaders is Salazar of
Portugal
um and you know Salazar is a very you
know like a very mild fascist but he
still has a secret police he still has
you know and and you know if you're even
in Mussolini's you know Italy before the
war if you're you know an anti-fascist
in Mussolini's Italy you get like sent
to an island you know and it's not
Auschwitz right and so you know the the
like sense of you know
the reason you know when you say like
what about the uyghurs you know for
example you're basically looking at a
regime which is insecure at a certain
level and it's basically
an insecure a certain level all regimes
are insecure at a certain level and
basically when you look at you know say
you know Elizabeth the first for example
so Elizabeth the first is under a
constant threat of being assassinated by
Catholics there are many you know
jesuitical plots against her and you
know the consequence of this is that you
know to be a Catholic in Elizabeth
Britain is no easy is no easy time
actually you know there are many
features of Elizabethan England that
make us think of dictatorships today
there's censorship of the press you know
there's a play by Ben Johnson Isle of
dogs which is lost because it lampooned
sort of powerful figures and yet also
when we look at these you know it
Elizabeth's England we're not looking at
a world like Stalin's Russia you know
where anyone could get in trouble for
any reason often completely spurious
we're not looking at a world like you
know I mean there were plenty of
Catholics and you know she didn't send
Catholics to the gulag and so you know
this is sort of she didn't send
Catholics to the death camps
um but if they tried to plot to
assassinate her yeah that was going to
be a problem and and so you know it's
sort of you know tempered by the kind of
level of of of insecurity there and and
that level of insecurity also you know
we're very fortunate to live in a
relatively you know non-violent age and
so when you look for example at the
uyghurs
um you know of course there are Central
Asian people and uh like many people
around the turn of the century kind of
um a lot of Saudi money and sort of went
in and they developed a terrorist
movement there which I think would
really kicked that off was this a bunch
of uyghurs went to I forget what city on
a train station and like started
massacreating people with knives and the
response of the Chinese government is
not you know certainly it's not uh I
mean this is of course posting you know
um it's not a response that you know
sort of matches what I would do at the
same time basically uh there's another
country which has a land border with
China
which is Afghanistan and you know uh and
when you look at basically the U.S
approach to Afghanistan and you're like
okay would I rather be a uyghur in you
know
um xinjiang or would I rather be live in
Afghanistan for 20 years of war and do
and watch this being done the American
way in which we spend two trillion
dollars and countless lives of ours and
theirs to basically take
um
Afghanistan from the Taliban and give it
to the the Taliban hold on but that
isn't the comparison we're talking about
we're talking about uh a Chinese style
authoritarianism sure versus the system
we have in the west right and and but
the system but but the system we have in
the west is a system for governing
Western people and so basically right
the reason the reason you know these
these I mean these countries are
neighbors they're very similar cultures
uh and so you know when we're sort of
comparing Apples to Apples you know
actually it's a very Apples to Apples
comparison to look at the Western system
of governing you know Afghanistan and
the Chinese system of governing what is
after all really a Chinese Colony uh of
xinjiang I just don't want to get
sidetracked into that let's stick with
the West right let's stick with the West
let's stick with the west and so and so
you know let's sort of take this you use
the word authoritarian
um and and the word authoritarian is a
very very interesting word because
um when you get into kind of basic you
know sort of again pre-enlightenment
political science you're reading like
Aristotle and so forth you know there is
really isn't anything in political sense
that Aristotle didn't understand and you
know one of my you know basic beliefs or
core beliefs you know we sort of have
this belief in like limited government
for example today every government is
unlimited every you know every
sovereignty is absolute sovereignty is
conserved and when you say you know
there's a you know a limited government
I just you know spoke you know okay in
America we have freedom of speech in
theory that's a British tradition uh you
know I just spoke with someone this
morning who is being investigated by the
police he's facing 14 years in prison
for satirical tweets
um and you know of course this is a you
know people being prosecuted for this
week which is a very common thing here
because I just wanna I understand what
you're saying and these are all good
points that we've covered on the show
plenty so the fact that Western
governments are violating some of
arguably the sacred principles of their
own societies is a problem and I agree
with it but I want to make a difference
no it's a different point but we mustn't
compare that to what we actually mean
when we say the word authoritarianism I
think yes and I think there's actually
there's there's a very important point
there and you know the sort of the
difference you know as I understand it
you describe yourself as a classical
liberal and so you see these kind of
principles I don't think I ever have but
it's it's not too far away it's not too
far it's not too far away and and and so
from the perspective of most people who
see this like woke authoritarianism or
whatever they kind of identify it as
somewhat new thing not certainly I
remember kind of the freedom speech on
the internet in in the 1990s when you
felt that anyone could say anything for
any reason and no one cared um and we've
come to a very different place from that
and so understanding the causes of that
and saying are the causes of that deeper
than this kind of you know superficial
question of how do we get past wokeness
how do we roll the clock back to the 90s
and and you know you're not gonna roll
back the clock tonight and I think it's
probably technological issue right the
the what the internet did is it changed
the way we communicate and so the the
authoritarianism that you see now it's a
response to the fact that Communications
become much more powerful than it ever
well it is it is it is but you know we
started we were talking about you know
World War II earlier and and you know
cancel called culture in specific and
let me tell a couple of stories so um
you know one of the things and and you
basically
you know
people who lose historical conflicts get
written out of History very easily and
so you don't understand
the age of what we call cancel culture
and so you know for example just as you
know I'll give you two examples
um one
um is a woman named Bella Dodd
completely forgotten by history she was
a member of the US polyp Bureau of the
cpusa she was a school teacher in New
York's communist school teacher in New
York City very like my grandmother a
little more successful in the party she
becomes a member of the Paula Peoria
she's a member of the faction of Earl
Browder who is basically pushing the
popular front line of unity between
liberals and Communists you know they
win the war World War II ends and
there's a split between the Liberals and
Communists sort of like the sign of
Soviet split I you know in some ways and
and you know sort of competing factions
of progressivism and as a result Stalin
who controls the American Communist
Party purges its leadership Browder has
purged and belladad has to be perched
and the way in which they Purge belladot
is very interesting you can read it in
an autobio Murphy School of Darkness
they basically accuse her of being
unfair to her Puerto Rican building
superintendent in fact they accuse her
of what was not at the time called
racial chauvinism but actually racism of
course this is completely untrue and so
if you wanted to be tried in a kangaroo
court and they had process within this
party literally they had kangaroo courts
if you wanted to be tried in a kangaroo
court for racism in the West in the
1940s
you had to be on the polypure of the car
of the Communist Party
um you know fast forward about 30 years
is a book that was republished recently
um called the romance of American
communism by lady named Vivian gornick
uh also a Russian Jewish communist of
Russian Jewish you know extraction
gornick grew up in the party in the 50s
uh you know and in the 70s she she falls
out of pure communism she becomes a new
leftist feminist this is not an
anti-leftist book which is one of the
things that makes it so valuable it was
recently republished by nyrb so you can
get your hands on the copy easily and
she's talking about cancel culture in
the 70s and you know in in the 60s
really and you know one of the things
these gifted kids these brilliant people
did in the party was they constantly
canceled each other long before and and
gornick would go in this amazing oral
history and she would speak to some
someone and they would be like oh the
cancellation you know impersonate oh the
cancellation was the worst it was so
terrible you know you got expelled from
the party and your friends would ignore
you in the grocery store it was awful
and then they talked to person B and
person B would be oh my God it was so
bad and the worst of them was personally
you know and and you know this so it
sort of became this kind of circular
firing squad you know which wasn't done
with bullets in the same way as Stalin
but was done you know uh by cancellation
so just to sort of broaden this out a
little bit you know yeah well that's why
I always say to people the late Soviet
Union was in stalinism but it was
exactly exactly which is why what's
happening you would lose your job you
would you're just like oh yeah this is
my grandfather Yeah right so I always
make this point to people in the west
that this this isn't new and here's the
parallel that you may want to think
about when you're this isn't new but let
me tell you a couple of other stories so
Browder
um I read this somewhere and
unfortunately I I I need a better
history historical researcher dig this
reference back up because I can't find
it now but it did in fact happen Browder
is making a secret speech to the party
to the American pilot Bureau in the
mid-30s and he's recounting the um
achievements of the comrades and he's
like one of the things that we've done
of course you know you know they sort of
took over Hollywood screenwriting and
made it almost a union shop of of party
writers but one of the things he says is
we have people in all the major
Publishers and anti-communist books can
no longer be published and when I read
material from the 30s and 40s and I've
read quite a bit of it you know of
course you probably heard the story of
like Animal Farm couldn't be published
oh yeah it goes far I mean but this is
what I always say to people right read
the preface to Animal Farm if you wanna
if you want to understand what
censorship actually is read the preface
right he talks about it it's not
somebody saying this book must be burned
it's the fact that you can't publish
anything without ever anyone ever
telling you why that's right that's
right and it goes and it goes you know
it goes far you know beyond Orwell
Orwell you know has is still kind of
sign of kind of in sympathy with these
these groups he doesn't get like super
canceled yeah but you know when you look
at American publishing in the 20s it
goes all the way from you know all this
communist stuff you know the new masses
go to marxist.org and read the archive
of the new masses it's like the New
Yorker for Communists in 1930 which is
to say the New Yorker sorry
and and joking
um and and you'll just see the mind of
the present in the past if you're
looking for people who have the same
world view as the average American
college student in 2023 and you're
looking for those people in 1923 1923
there's very few of them they're
overwhelmingly social Elites you'll find
them in places like Greenwich Village I
always advise people to watch the film
Reds which is a very you know with
Warren Beatty as John Reed young John
Reed only American buried in the wall
the Kremlin and you basically see these
people with these insanely modern
attitudes they live like people in San
Francisco their lives love lives are
like the love lives of people in San
Francisco these are completely modern
people and they're a very small minority
and they basically set out to take power
so here's a couple of examples that are
sort of a little outside of the normal
space of like anti-wokness so basically
you know this thing with the Publishers
is done and the sort of kind of defines
what it means to be like mainstream
media what it means to be mainstream
publishing is that you kind of went
through this filtration this
coordination
um it was very different process in Nazi
Germany but this ideological
coordination which was centralized in
Nazi Germany
except for the cpusa which is long gone
uh it was decentralized in this country
wokeness is decentralized but it appear
it achieves the same uh you know purpose
as I'm going to butcher the German
collection you know which is basically
turning everything the sort of turning
everything Nazi that uh you know happen
in the Third Reich you know my favorite
example this is a wonderful writer
Victor Klemperer do you know the name he
was a Jew who survived the Third Reich
because he was married to an Aryan and
his wife was he was his wife was a nerd
he was a linguist so we were at this
wonderful book called language of the
Third Reich
um he wound up in East Germany so his
his Works were not he was actually
member of these German Parliament later
and so his works you know were not
widely known until the 90s and he has
this one story in which he he had a cat
the cat does not survive the words to
someone sad story he had a chat and he
subscribed to a cat magazine and in 1931
won his cat magazine was all about cats
but by 1935 it was all about the German
and and so you know you you've started
to see the German cat everywhere and so
here's one other story about basically
can I just interrupt you just a second
because the point you might think I
really agree with yes I agree with it
with the authoritarian element of it the
problem I have is
the monarchy and you you're saying we
need a monarchy yet you have used the
example in previous interviews of Google
being a monarchy that's right yeah
Google or one of the instruments that
silences people online so that doesn't
that doesn't that contradict your
insurance so so Google you know I I'm
I'm a Silicon Valley person so so
um you know I'm sort of very familiar
with kind of the the way this thinking
has evolved over time and you know where
are these sort of centralized social
media providers came out of everyone who
started these things had this kind of
90s light libertarian ideology of
Silicon Valley that I used to believe in
and it used to be you could publish
absolutely anything you know
um on Blogger and when you looked when
you look at how these companies became
these enforcers it was quite unwilling
and they basically I mean now you know
the sort of
um
they they didn't want to do this and
they basically sort of felt themselves
under the same kind of decentralized
constraint that basically gave us sort
of the German cat right and and and you
know you'll notice for example that you
have you know and this is kind of one of
the the fundamental conundrums of our
society you know I coined the term the
cathedral to refer to these kind of the
mainstream intellectual basically
newspapers and Academia and one of the
things you note is that this is
nominally decentralized system with all
these separate polls you know in Nazi
Germany you have gibbles in his ministry
of Enlightenment and he's like yo you
must be enlightened this way that way
right you know but not just to translate
your point into sort of simpler language
what you're saying basically is it's
decentralized no one is sitting at the
top going everyone everyone must have
equity and diversity no one's doing that
but everyone must have Equity but
everyone must have and so you have the
same effect that Google's was trying to
generate yeah but the mechanism is
totally different right and and it's a
fascinating question of what this
mechanism is okay cool so we've got
about 10 minutes left I want to leave
before we move on to locals and have the
conversation there let's use the last 10
minutes in a little bit more succinct
concrete way to talk about that
mechanism why is it that we're now
obsessed with the German care why is it
that the same ideological positions are
being pushed on everybody from
corporations the media Parliament down
the road from here the church right I
mean I I could the the NHS everyone is
ad hoc to a particular worldview and you
can even believe that's a great world
view and it's exactly everyone needs
equity and diversity and whatever how is
that mechanism that is the mechanism
there is no more important question Cool
let's take 10 minutes very specifically
and talk about that is the most
important question of the time and the
answer is because we're not a monarchy
and and and and and and let me let me
let me be really you know specific and
clear about that yeah
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
internet National celebrity who's
appeared on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
you know Aristotle let's go back to
Aristotle Aristotle is like there are
three forms of government monogram
monarchy oligarchy and democracy you
have the rule of the one the many and
the few these are actually forms of
power rather than forms of government so
these forms of power exist you know in
every society you know you look at you
know the Kennedys in America you know
there's an element of monarchy there but
overwhelmingly you know you have this
fellow Michael Young you're at the rise
of the meritocracy a father of Toby
Young I believe
um you know an Englishman and we use
this word meritocracy we mean this sort
of institutional oligarchy in which
decisions are made through process
and the whole idea of the 20th century
is essentially that politics has failed
the idea of politicians running the
state is horrifying to people it leads
to Hitler that's what happens Hitler was
elected worldless democratically as a
politician as a demagogue and you're
basically like you know what if we let
elected politicians run the state we get
demagoguery we get Hitler it's all true
that's what happened that's what we got
right and so you know the response to
that was sort of to use the word
democracy when you talk about liberal
democracy Civil Society you know sort of
the world of of George Soros
and you know I think one thing that's
worth reflecting on is the way we use
the word democracy in politics so you
might notice that the word democracy has
a very positive connotation and the word
politics has a very negative connotation
and there's synonyms
and and so when we say liberal democracy
Civil Society what we really mean is
that the government should be run by
professors and journalists and when
those professors and journalists and
civil servants like my parents are
basically told what to do by politicians
let's say the politicians can even fire
them you know that's horrifying that
leads us down the road to Hitler and so
you know the principle of the sort of
you know technocratic meritocratic
government is that the government should
be ruled by experts and these expert the
ideas of these experts exist in a
Marketplace of ideas which is not the
sort of democratic Marketplace of ideas
it gives us q and on and you know weird
anti-vaxxer internet stuff you know
that's a terrible Marketplace of ideas
everything that people say about it is
true
um
and but the marketplace of ideas among
informed experts and you're just like
how could this go wrong
and let me give you an example that sort
of has nothing to do with wokeness
nothing to do with the journal hold on
let me just work through what you're
saying so that the logic is clear well
it's very easy to see how that goes
wrong uh on because if you if the idea
of democracy is essentially that you can
get rid of the coach right if you don't
like the coach well if the coach isn't
actually in charge yes if the coach
actually is in charge the wire is
leading to the election you can replace
the coach but the team is still going to
be run the way that is by the managers
the trainers right and so and and so you
know what you know and this is really
this is very old thing this is you know
American progressivism essentially from
the early part of the century you know
you going back in history you have this
sort of Gilded Age system in America
very like China a very corrupt very
effective you know and the politicians
are these these Scoundrels these corrupt
people very uneducated very broad you
know things get done in a messy way and
you know the old American Elites uh you
know I mean people like Henry Adams for
example really the earliest progressives
the farther you go back in progressivism
the more I like these people and and the
uh and they're just like you know this
Society should be ruled by the best
people in it and these people are
manifestly not the best people they are
not the experts they are not the
smartest people but who gets to judge
who the best people are because well at
present who gets to judge who the best
people are are these institutions right
and so let me basically you know the
meritocracy essentially now you know it
gets corrupted by you know all this race
stuff or whatever but you know let me
give you an example of of a problem that
we're all familiar with and the effect
in this and that example is covet y'all
remember covid and you've probably had
yeah you probably had covet yes and so I
think it's fairly clearly established
it's not really a right-wing conspiracy
theory it's fairly clear that if it
didn't happen it could have happened
um and here's how covet happens so first
you have SARS one which basically jumps
from a bat to a palm civet it's very
well established very nasty disease and
um
this
you know as hard as one is a problem it
only escapes it almost becomes coveted
and it kills about 20 of the people that
have it and makes Delta covid which was
a nasty disease you know look like the
common cold it's an important problem
the way science is funded
specifically science and you know
including for example virology virology
is not social sciences very clearly
scientific it's a hard science and and
in in the um and the principle of the
second half of the 20th century the way
that science has funded is sort of you
know um consistent with this kind of
government by experts principle which
and the thing about an oligarchy is it
almost looks like it's no government at
all it's just like no there's no power
here it's just it's just science it's
not power it's just science you know but
when you look more closely at human
power there's always human beings
involved and so the result of SARS one
is that virology becomes important and
specifically bat coronaviruses become
important and the way science having
like dropped out of my PhD program but
you know some people think of me as a
computer scientist the way science works
is you get funding for things that are
important and things that matter
and So within virology basically people
realize that they could get quite a bit
of Grants by referring to this very real
problem with bad coronaviruses and they
basically said well you know this is a
serious problem uh we deserve
um a number of pounds to study it and so
they're like what if this happened again
what if a bat coronavirus emerged well
let's go and find all the background
viruses let's go to all the bat caves
they literally did this let's bring the
viruses back but the problem is these
viruses are bad viruses they don't
naturally infect humans but they could
mutate to infect humans but waiting for
them to mutate very slow and random
process
so what if we mutated them and what if
we train them what if we put if you're
in cleavage site in what if we trained
them to infect you know humanized mice
what if we did this in a Chinese
laboratory with very poor biosafety
conditions you know
the Wuhan virus was not that's an
American virus because it's funded by
American Science these people were
literally funded to do this research by
American grants and so when you talk to
the you know the virologists who did
this they're like well we need to
predict the emergency well what happens
if you predict it what do you do we
predicted it all right you know and it's
like you find you know come home and you
find your 10 year old sitting fire to
the kitchen curtains and you're like why
are you sitting fire to the curtains
he's like well you know there's a lot of
fires in the kitchen cooking happens
there are accidents what if the curtains
caught fire could we get out could the
dog get out so so so gain of function
research at least in this context is
clearly a bad idea and yet this bad idea
which you know any Fool on the street
can see is a bad idea basically succeeds
in the marketplace of ideas that you
know consists of professional
virologists with IQs of 150 who have
trained for many many years to study
this and the question of why this bad
idea succeeds in the marketplace of
ideas is fundamental to the question of
why bad ideas you know rule our society
today and how we tend you know like
the difference between gain of function
research and the idea that colleges
should discriminated in missions by the
skin color of the people applying to
them you know they're both equally
ridiculous ideas right and how do these
ridiculous ideas succeed and when we use
words like authoritarianism which is
basically
um sort of an anti-monarchical word uh
we're basically looking at the sort of
the the pathologies of monarchies which
are systems very alien to the in very
opposed to the kind of oligarchy that
runs our Democratic societies today and
monarchies you know when they fail when
they're bad and any system of government
can democracy oligarchy or monarchy can
be good or bad
basic point of Aristotle when when bad
Authority when bad monarchies distort
the marketplace of ideas it's
overwhelmingly by repressing good ideas
[Music]
um and the way that we got here is very
different from that it's by A system
that promotes bad ideas
moreover it promotes bad ideas not
through a sort of conscious monarchical
plan there's no little counsel to
Supreme Elders or something sitting in a
little room saying we're gonna you know
fund this bad idea because we like bad
ideas uh that would be better in some
ways because it would be easy to get rid
of those people but there's actually
there's no Center
there's no little cabal there's no
dictatorship there's sort of none of
that there's just a system that's
structurally rewards these bad ideas and
it structurally rewards these bad ideas
first of all by separating Authority
from responsibility and so you know is
someone like you know fauci who's almost
you know a little monarch within this
oligarchical structure of process you
know and who is really you know critical
in you know sort of authorizing and
continuing this gain of function
research will never be held accountable
and so you have this kind of division
this you know when bad ideas are
accountable they are not they're not not
favored in the in the evolutionary
darwinian contest of ideas but when you
look at the way bad ideas are promoted
and it's simply enough to not have that
accountability and when you don't have
that accountability the attraction of
bad ideas not the sort of repulsive if
you think about like electromagnetic
force you have really traction and
repulsion and what happens is basically
you have these bad ideas
and they feel good for some reason
within virology for example gain of
function research feels good because
everyone's doing it it's the way to get
grants and if you say no one should be
doing this you're basically selling
saying your fellow virologist should not
be funded that's gonna be hard all right
but the thing is you know when you
basically extend that outside the
circles of experts essentially you know
when these experts are promoting
policies that strengthen power that
reward them they're like my field is
important my field is matter it matters
more must be done and then you extend
this to sort of the broader world where
does this sort of culture of of
victimology come from whether you're
looking we talked about communism
progressivism earlier and if you look at
for example the Scottsboro boys case of
you know which is promoted by Communists
in the 1930s you connect that to George
Floyd there's sort of this clear thread
there and and and there's you know
providing people with a feeling of
saying I'm the defender of the victim
you know I am the White Knight I am the
Paladin I am standing up you know for
and and you know the effect of these
ideas may be terrible I mean I think the
effect of the George Floyd riots on you
know the African-American community in
America is straightforwardly negative
it's just very clear social science
statistics massive numbers of deaths
from Deep policing right but that
doesn't have an accountability impact on
the marketplace of ideas
what impacts the marketplace of ideas is
what you should just say that because
sorry to translate what you're saying
into simple language the people who push
that narrative didn't get the
comeuppance they should have got yes
they were not delegitimized he
legitimized but they felt that positive
feeling yes of feeling incredibly good
about it their hearts felt warm they
felt important they felt like they
mattered yes they felt like it gave them
meaning right and so you know the sort
of marketing that kind of meaning which
is confined in the 1930s to a very small
Elite set of like American Communists
including my forebears basically becomes
Mass Market in you know the sort of
George Floyd experience now every
Suburban housewife feels like they
matter like they're standing up and what
they don't realize it's that is that
that's a mechanism that not only
promotes bad ideas the bad ideas
displace good ideas and you get this
kind of monoculture which looks exactly
like the kind of Monaco culture in at
least structurally I'm not saying
whether you know it looks exactly the
like the kind of monoculture that's
enforced through repressive means by an
authoritarian government such as Nazi
Germany but the mechanism that basically
creates that coordination of ideology is
promotion rather than suppression it's
attraction rather than repulsion and
it's completely it's inevitable in an
oligarchical meritocratic structure of
government and so when these oligarchies
were established you had these
marketplaces of ideas you know
professors had never been involved in
government the idea that professors
should run the government in 1900 was as
absurd as saying Postman should run the
government and because these
marketplaces of ideas in Academia were
not corrupted by power
they were flat and they were excellent
and people were like okay I have these
corrupt politicians elected by you know
democracy
um terrible result you know we'll see
username democracy just as we saw using
the name monarchy but politicians are
awful they're corrupt what about these
unbiased you know experts but the thing
is you give power to the experts and
power corrupts them and suddenly they
become they develop these conflicts of
interest they become sort of corrupted
and basically when you give power to the
marketplace of ideas the marketplace of
ideas corrupts itself and you get
basically a world of absolutely terrible
ideas
Curtis it's an absolute pleasure thank
you so much for coming on the show last
question we always ask is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
um I'm gonna go back to something that I
said earlier about technology and I
think the thing that we're not talking
about when we talk about technology
is uh you know Technology's destruction
of Labor demand and and the way it makes
you know absolutely ruthlessly acts to
make human beings useless and I think
one of the reasons why the future needs
a kind of state power I used to be a
Libertarian I love being a Libertarian I
I describe myself as a recovering
libertarian I'll always be a Libertarian
in a way and and you know one of the
things that has happened to these
societies is that you know you have a
society go to the tower blocks you know
10 miles from here you have this these
buildings full of absolutely useless
people and they're just decaying in the
most horrific way
and you know this and this is a very
long train of history that starts with
you know Goldsmith's deserted village
you know like all the labor demand for
like the local blacksmith disappears and
then you know his grandchildren have
this horrific dickensian existence where
they're used as human robots and now we
don't even need human robots anymore
because we have robots and then suddenly
Along come these large language models
and they start working killing the
demand for basically what um David
Graber called jobs suddenly
like paper pushing is is under attack
and you're like whoa I thought I could
have a career pushing papers and
suddenly you can't and and so you know
we have you know the system of
technology is you know economics refer
economists refer to you know technology
as basically productivity you and
they're and you're just like increasing
productivity is good more productivity
is better more stuff is better and less
stuff and we come into this economy
where there's actually demand for like
10 guys who write you know 10 you know
men and women who write the large
language models and then the large
language models start writing themselves
and that's the real AI disaster is that
you don't need people anymore it's not
that they'll like revolt against people
in some sort of Golem myth it's that you
don't need people anymore and so you
know the way the only way to prevent
that
is a sort of you know regime which says
okay yes we better wrap up because
there's a protest against
um you know when you're basically saying
you know
the purpose of government is the health
of the people not the luxury of the
people not the wealth of the people but
the health of the people you go back to
thinkers like John Ruskin and and
Carlisle who are like wait a second you
know power needs to step in and power
needs to basically regulate the economy
to make people need it and that's a very
hard and deep question and I'm sure
people are protesting are they
protesting me I don't know we'll we'll
find out Curtis Yavin thank you so much
for coming on and we've got a great
section for locals with Curtis coming
right up head on over there and we'll
see you there
U.S currency and no
and over the list I'm trying to work out
if Mr yarvin believes we are rather
royalty should continue to use a facade
of a god which might not exist in
reference to emblems and symbols which
are used to ceremony bind us
[Music]